welcome back to the David Pakman show
I'm Ferren cousins in for David Pakman
today and tomorrow
and David's down in South Florida he's
got a media and cryptocurrency event
that he's attending so I will be taking
care of all of your political and news
needs for the next day or two so before
the break we were talking about the fact
that Donald Trump's finances could be
what Muller is going after next in this
investigation following the indictments
of the 13 Russians and the three Russian
agencies spreading propaganda during the
2016 election while we don't know for
sure if it is Trump himself and his
finances that's going to be the next big
shoe to drop in this investigation what
we do know what broke the day after all
of these indictments came down was that
Robert Muller is 100% looking into the
finances of Jared Kushner his family and
their businesses specifically Robert
Muller wants to find out a little bit
more about the financing the lending and
the loans and all of that of certain
properties held by Kushner and his
families accounts specifically some of
the deals that seemed to take place
during the transition and since Jared
Kushner became an official with the
Donald Trump white house here it is
they've been asking a lot of questions
of Kushner's business associates and one
of the things they're trying to figure
out is what happened with the financing
for 666 5th Avenue that's one of the big
questions the timing of this this
particular deal that they had is very
questionable according to the
investigators they want to know if
Kushner's potential connections to the
incoming Trump administration being a
son-in-law if that played any role in
helping to secure any of the financing
and furthermore even without potential
quid pro quo there was this financing on
the level
and one of the reasons that they want to
know the answers to these questions is
because completely separate from the
Muller investigation is the fact that
the IRS has also opened up an
investigation into Jared Kushner and his
family and their finances and their
business dealings so Jared Kushner right
now finds himself smack in the middle of
two separate investigations about
potentially shady business deals that he
and his family have been making again
this IRS investigation that was first
announced I believe late last week has
nothing to do with what's going on with
the Muller investigation this is a
separate government organization the IRS
looking at his financials and his
family's financials and they're saying
you know what something doesn't quite
smell right here we need to get to the
bottom of this and meanwhile Robert
Muller and his team after going through
all of the information that they've gone
through they've gone through tax returns
they've subpoenaed banks and they
decided you know what something's not
right here with the Kushner clan let's
go ahead and start to focus more on that
in this investigation so if you remember
you know months ago when Donald Trump
said robert muller better stay away from
the finances don't go looking over there
there's nothing in there for you to see
so don't open that door and robert
muller basically said yeah i'm gonna go
ahead and open that door then this is
what trump didn't want people to see
maybe it involves Trump himself but
right now we know that there was enough
evidence from two separate organizations
the special prosecutor's office and the
IRS to kind of hone the focus of these
on - Jared Kushner's business dealings
so they want to know they want to know
where all the money's coming from they
want to know where he's spending it and
more importantly they want to know is he
using his office within the White House
to curry favor with foreign governments
to make deals for new Trump properties
or for new investments into properties
in the United States what is he doing
and I think that question though
what is he doing is probably one of the
best questions to ask of the Trump
administration today
why is Jared Kushner even there what
does he do why does he still have a
security clearance even though he hasn't
formally been cleared by the
intelligence apparatus in the United
States to have access to full classified
data hey this guy has had to amend his
disclosure forms for his security
clearance I believe at least a dozen
times maybe even more than that
sometimes one day right after another
and he still can't seem to get it right
he had misidentified his classification
on his absentee ballot from this past
November he couldn't fill out that form
correctly so given what we've seen from
Jared Kushner and all of his I guess
missteps with handling forms and filling
out documents I would bet that if there
is anything to either of these
investigations whether it's the IRS or
the special prosecutor's office looking
into him I think for certain that
they're going to find that Kushner
himself was involved and I mean no
disrespect but come on this guy is
certainly not the sharpest knife in the
drawer I mean again with all the times
he's had to amend his disclosure forms I
can't seem to get it right so I think if
they're gonna find anything on Trump
it's gonna have to come through Kushner
he has screwed up so many times that
there's got to be something in there
that this guy is done wrong or something
he did that he thought he'd get away
with and now he can't because he's got
all of these different investigations
into him and if they catch him on
something will he be the one to turn on
Donald Trump he certainly seems like it
I mean he kind of seems like the
stereotypical Squealer that you see in
movies you know the the guy that gets
caught and he's like alright I'll tell
you everything just just don't walk me
away I'm I can't go to jail
that's Kushner in my opinion and so
maybe that's why all of these
investigations right now seem to be
focusing on him because they could be
looking at him as the key to unlock
whatever it is Donald Trump himself is
hiding